adrian cambana should be looking forward
to christmas
but instead this year
like the three before
she'll be without her husband
jimmy mubenga died as he was being
deported to angola
he was on a plane
on a runway at heathrow airport
but just before takeoff
something went tragically wrong
i was in my home when the police called
me but i didn't know it was there i
thought it was jimmy
because they used jimmy's phone
jimmy mubinga died on board the aircraft
after being heavily restrained for more
than half an hour in a position that
would eventually kill him
terence hughes seen here on your right
colin kayla
and stuart treibelnig were the custody
officers who were tasked with taking mr
mubinga back to africa
his death
led to them facing a charge of
manslaughter
several witnesses on board flight ba77
say they heard jimmy mubenga pleading
for his life
let me go i can't breathe he said over
and over again
the prosecution claims the defendants
ignored those pleas
they say they didn't hear those words
uttered
whenever we're taking an escort
it's important to make sure that in the
seated position the escort is kept as
upright as possible eric baskind is an
expert on the use of force
he showed us how mr mubenga should have
been restrained so from this relaxed
position in the event that the detainee
starts to struggle
then the guard behind can make sure that
his head is kept upright
that the staff either side can restrain
him and in the event that he's
struggling he's going to be kept in an
upright position
and then he showed us how mr mubinga was
held
so in the event of a struggle what would
happen is that the guard in front was
pulling the head down and pulling the
head down in any of these positions
that's almost certainly the most
dangerous position that we can think of
in restraint it's simply because their
lung function is going to be compromised
they will have difficulty in breathing
mr mubinga's death has led to a review
in the way forced deportations are
carried out by the government
but campaigners say the process is still
not transparent enough
an earlier inquest into jimmy benga's
death led the cps to re-examine the case
and criminal charges and the trial
followed
adrienne has welcomed the change in the
way deportees are restrained
but it's come too late for her i don't
want to see any another family to suffer
like
we have done
it's very very very painful
ashish joshi sky news